Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
Okay. What's going.
On guys? This is Rob and we are covering.
King and black part two. Yes.
Oh, we're we're in kingdom, black. The officials second issue of King of like,
I guess it's not really part two. Cause we, we had what,
like the venom tie in that we had the incredible whole tie-in.
I still need to do iron man and Dr. Doom,
because I feel like that one's insanely good up,
but we're covering part two of King and black, right. Issue number two.
And this basically picks up with Eddie Brock,
like falling presumably to his death or at least it looked like his death.
Right. We had that amazing issue in venom where the whole thing took,
took place over the span of something like,
what is it like 33 seconds or something like that. It's like this just,
it was amazing the way that it was done.
So any broad crash lands down into the ground, right? Like,
like literally hitting all these different things along the way he crashed,
landed down to the ground. Spiderman comes swinging into the rescue right now.
Here's the thing Spider-Man is like one of the last hero standing here in New
York, right? There's there's a few others more find out who they are,
but for the most part, most heroes are basically gone.
And the initial thought of Spiderman is like,
he like Eddie Brock is dead and he tried to race back here and get to Eddie as
fast as he could. But he couldn't right now.
Here's the important thing to understand about this.
This is one of the coolest things, right?
And it's not heavily mentioned here and it's only released something you pick up
on if you've been reading for a reasonable amount of time,
but this whole scene is beautiful and amazing, right?
Because these guys have been enemies over the years, right?
They've been pretty extreme enemies over the years. Eddie Brock first showed up,
not really for shut up, but when he first became venom,
he was like Peter Parker sworn enemy. He's like,
I'm gonna do everything I can to kill you and destroy your life.
And he went after Peter Parker's family, the whole nine yards, right.
He would just asymmetrical war on Peter.
And now you have a scenario where Eddie Brock looks like he's about to die.
And Peter feels totally ashamed of himself that he couldn't make it here in
time. Right. Screaming for help calling for help.
Now Eddie Brock wakes up and then basically tells Peter like Dylan. Right?
Promise me that you'll look after Dylan now for no himself.
He kind of makes us this sort of, sort of funny remark. And it's like, honestly,
how hard is it to kill one, man? Well, not hard if you do it properly. No,
because all you had to do was like terrorist head off or rip his heart out of
his body or rip them in half or Tara's arms and legs off or any number of the
things that you could have done besides just dropping him to his death.
Here's the funny thing about this, like obviously is it's like,
this is for the sake of the story,
but it's one of these funny things where like you have villains and kind of
books who get frustrated over the fact that they can't kill us,
kill a character all the while glossing over any one of the infinite number of
easy ways to do it, right?
Like any one of the infinite number of easy ways to kill these guys.
And so it's kind of a funny little thing to me,
but ultimately like the spider sense of Peter Parker kicks in when he suddenly
met by an optic glass from Cyclops.
And that's when he realizes all these heroes that were fighting here in New
York, they were not killed by Knoll. They were conscripted into NOLs army.
Now we largely assumed this is what was exactly what was going to happen because
we saw Ben and beyond, right?
And we saw this alternate reality where Dylan basically became a person who
conquered earth and essentially turned all superheroes to aside by forcing
symbionts on them.
And in some cases that they were already dead turning the symbionts into those
guys. But the long and short of this is that we kind of saw this coming. Right.
And so Peter Parker basically tries to get out of there as fast as he can.
But for the most part, he kind of seems truck when, out of nowhere,
right out of, out of nowhere comes Johnny storm right now.
Here's the funny thing my initial thought to this, my in my initial thought was,
Oh my God, that's right.
Johnny storm has a built-in immunity to symbionts because he can flame on,
right? Like that's, that was my, my immediate thought. And I was like, Oh no,
wait a minute. These Grendel's are not like venom. Right.
They're stronger than that.
You can't just torch them with fire and call it a day. Otherwise,
all you would do is have the superheroes running around with aerosol cans and
lighters. Right. Just spraying down everything in front of them.
And that would be it, right. This story will be over like that. It'd be,
it'd be over lickety split, but it's still cool here because,
because Johnny storm could easily become just written in here.
It's like the saving grace.
And he has had those moments while you guys remember in Jonathan,
Hickman's fantastic for what? Like the portal opens up like,
like literally the portal to the, to the negative zone opens up and like,
it opens up inside the fantastic four Baxter building and like,
like everybody's panicking. They're freaking out. Like Johnny goes in there,
he's like close the portal behind me. Right. So they shut the portal behind him.
He turns around phases like this hoard of like,
like a billion members of the annihilation wave. And it's just like flame on.
Right. And then, and then like, it cuts like it, it just ends. And it's like,
you're just like the greatest cliffhanger ever in the history of comics plays
amazing moment. But, but nonetheless,
Johnny storm has had those moments and where he realizes that, yeah,
he can't really just blast the symbionts with his fire and kind of bring them to
an end. He goes so far as to say, then fine,
I'll let off my Nova blast when that happened, Peter, Parker's like, let's go.
Right. Because when the Nova blast goes off from Johnny storm,
if you're in the vicinity, you are dead. And there's no arguing that point.
It's literally the sun exploding is what it is right here. Like he reaches,
I think at, or near the temperature of the sun when he does his Nova blocks.
Right. Just lets everything off. Now the downside of this is when that happens.
It's basically expanding all of his energy at one time.
Of course he passes out and that's something that Peter Parker says, like,
if you do this, you're going to pass out and they're going to take you.
He's like, yeah, I know, but it can buy you time. Right.
It can buy you time to get out of here. And so that's exactly what Peter does.
Right? He webs up Eddie Brock. He gets him out of there.
And then he takes them over to the Homebase,
the laboratory of the fantastic four and the Baxter building.
Now here's the thing we basically ended up picking up here with Valkyrie. Now,
for those of you guys who don't know what's going on with the character of
Valkyrie, Jane Foster now plays that role.
And what Marvel did here in the aftermath of Jason Aaron's run on, on Thor. Oh,
I love Jane Foster Thor. I don't really care if you didn't like it. I loved it.
Right. And your opinion's not going to change mine,
but I love the whole story there.
But what they ended up doing is because Odin's son was going to go back to being
Thor, just like I always said,
he would be because it's comics and everything old goes back to the way
everything goes back to the way that it used to be. Right?
The status quo is always maintain that this led to Marvel kind of shuffling Jane
Foster out, right? She got shuffled off to the cornfields and her own,
his own comic. That was never really advertised all that well. And, uh,
as she's basically been Valkyrie ever since, what does she do?
She basically shepherds those from the land of the living to the, of the dead.
And the reason why this matters is because she has this kind of power or ability
more or less to know how close somebody is to death and where Peter Parker asks,
how close is Eddie Brock to dine? She's like, well, you know,
I can tell you enough to say you better hurry up, right?
Because he's basically almost done with all his living. So it was like, okay,
so you basically end up having Peter Parker who goes, and he grabs Dylan. Now,
as soon as he gets into this room where Dylan's being hidden,
as soon as Dylan sees Spiderman, he's like, okay, bye. Basically like he asks,
the question is my dad dead, you know, is, is my dad basically dead and gone?
And Peter's response is no, like not what I left him, but you know,
we need to get you and we need to get outta here. Now, something to understand,
this is kind of an interesting thing here.
Peter can't really look Dylan in the eye.
And this is a small thing to notice is a very, very small thing,
easy to overlook. But this is shame, right?
A person who can't look you in the eye,
whenever they've done something wrong is a person who shamed or feeling guilt
for what it is that they did wrong.
Peter believes he did something wrong by not being able to save the life of
Eddie Brock. Again,
tying into this history between the two and how significant it is.
But once we end up having Peter grab, grab Dylan,
and then head back to the fantastic four's, uh, base of operations,
there's a handful of heroes here, right? We've got Reed Richards.
We've got Susan storm. We don't really know where Franklin and Valeria are.
Presumably they're being kept somewhere safe. You've got black Panther here.
You've got blade, right? You've got, um,
you've got Charles Xavier and Magneto who were showing up in the form of
holograms. And you literally have blade asking them like open your Gates, right?
So we can basically go there and you have no idea how many people you can say.
The smart thing here for [inaudible] to do is to actually keep their Gates
closed. And the reason why I know on the servers,
it seems kind of Callison kind of cruel. But in times like this,
you can't let the wrong people in. And when I say the wrong people,
all it's going to take is for one Simbi that nobody knows about to be bonded to
a person. And they're not even aware of it, right.
It's just stowed away on a backpack or something like that.
And then suddenly the entirety of cocoa's basically being taken over by
symbions. Right? No one knows exactly how to get there.
He goes in just bust into the place and they're all taken over. Right?
So the smartest thing to do in any situation like this is to shut your doors and
to say, no, you can't get in, right.
We're I'm sorry about your luck is such as things are going South,
but we can't take the risk of losing our people because of what's going on out
there. Ah, sorry about your luck.
Hopefully you find a better way to take care of it.
Now the X-Men don't necessarily leave the other superheroes hanging,
feel like we can formulate a plan together,
but we're not going to open our doors and let you in because we're going to let
the wrong person in and everything is going to come to an end.
The other part of this is that black Panther starts asking questions, says,
okay, with everything going on here, like, yes,
Wakanda's obviously going to fight,
but what do we have in terms of like huge weapons of power, right?
Do we have the infinity stones, the cosmic cube, the ultimate notifier?
What do we have on hand that can bring an end to note,
another responsive blade is,
do we really need that kind of firepower and Valerie cottage Himes Dan.
And it's like, you know what blade, here's the deal, man.
We're talking about a guy who existed before existence existed. Right?
And then like he killed, he killed some Celestials.
He was locked away for a little while.
Now he's back and he's taken over the celestial.
So he's powerful enough to conquer Celestials he's here on our world and we're
losing by not even a little bit. So yeah.
I kind of think the idea of talking about the infinity gauntlet or the cosmic
cube or the ultimate notifier is kind of a good idea because at this point,
what, what else do we have left?
It's literally been less than 30 minutes and we've all pretty much been
conquered right? In the span of 30 minutes.
Pretty much all the superheroes on earth have been totally taken over. Now,
this is when we get the introduction of name or the submariner.
And this is a cool thing here because Susan storm is the one that called them in
now, Reed kind of pulls her aside and says, Hey cam,
can we kind of talk privately for a second?
And the reason why is because Nemours and Susan's dorm kind of have a history
where they pretty much just bumped uglies a few times, right?
Like she kinda cheated on read a few times,
at least Marvel heavily alluded to it.
There were a couple of times when Marvel was like, no, she never actually did.
But if you go back and you read the original source material,
she pretty much dead. Right? I mean,
that's basically what happened at the very least.
There was the idea of her leaving read for namer, but, but name, workshop,
you know, showing up here is kind of like, look like here's the thing.
My entire race has been fighting in the shadows for millennia, right?
Like we've been fighting all these crazy enemies that are out there.
You're losing this war and you're losing it by a lot. Right.
So if you want to succeed, you're going to need my help right now.
My people are here and my guys are here.
Does anybody here have anything that even remotely resembles a plan
and Tony stark chimes in and says I do, but it's going to be crazy. Right?
It's going to be a crazy, ridiculous plan. So he's got, he's like,
I've got this plan and I've got a few others that I'm trying to work on here.
But what we need to understand here is that Eddie Brock is the only one that's
going to be able to save us. And I need to get one of the dragons from no,
right now here's the thing. If you're a superhero in this room and you're like,
does anybody here have a plan, an iron man's like, yeah, man,
but I'm going to need a dragon. It's kind of like, okay, cool.
Let's go see if we could find a dragon. They're like.
You don't really question the.
Plans of iron man. Right? Tony, soccer's a futurist.
He's always thinking in the future. And depending on the circumstance,
he's actually smarter than anybody else in this room. Again,
it depends on what situation that we're talking about here.
But because he thinks about things in a,
in a far more interesting way and in a far more new, a far more nuanced way,
thinking more about the future, then thinking about today,
it really puts them kind of ahead of everybody else.
And so one of the things that happens is we have this group called the black
tide, which are basically like, what is it? The things from a Aquaman.
I don't remember exactly what they're called like in before DC fans are like SU
Marvel steals from Duc. And before those guys, because you know,
they're going to post in the comment section. But, um, but yeah,
like it's basically these enemies that are out there that Ironman knew about
that, uh, that, that, that name of the sub Mariner didn't think he did,
but these guys are cowered by like dark magic.
But the idea is to rally them to their cause at the same time you have blade who
traveled travels to Chernobyl in Ukraine and then basically tells like, Dracula,
we need your help. You switched to the bar with no name in New York.
And you have the, have the mayor of New York, Wilson Fisk,
the kingpin who comes walking in and it's like,
does anybody want to make some money? Right. It's all hands on deck.
It's basically like, there's no more villains. And in this,
in this whole study where there's no heroes, no is just survivors.
That's all this is.
And we're gonna all going to have to like put these problems aside and work in
unison. If we're going to pull this off now for iron man's part,
he ends up taking off and literally flying into New York and then traveling to
one of the dragons right now,
the reason why the dragon is being used is because these beings seem to have the
closest connection to know than any other of the other symbionts that are out
there. Right? So it effectively makes them the strongest quote unquote.
And so Ironman basically gets in there and says, okay, cool. You know,
I'm going to have to essentially rewrite this guy's DNA, right?
I'm going to have treat it like a computer program, right?
If I have a computer program that's not working the way that I want it to,
then I just rewrite the code and then get it to do what I want it to do.
That's what he's talking about here. Right?
Rewriting the DNA of this entire thing to make it subservient to the heroes and,
and really took how to follow the direction of Ironman as opposed to following
the directions of Nope.
The problem with this is that while he uses extremis and he gets in there and
starts, you know, kind of manipulating this guy's DNA starts tapping into it.
What he starts to realize is that these are all connected through a hive mind.
Now we already knew that, right? We,
as the reader already knew that a hive mind is what connects all these things
under. No, but they're all experiencing constant pain, right? Pain, anguish,
suffering. It's just millions of voices,
all screaming at the same time to the point that it actually starts to overwhelm
Ironman. Now, ultimately it does not.
And it basically leads to him traveling back to where Eddie Brock is and then
taking the Symbian and then pouring it on the, any life, taking this Grindle,
putting it on any Brock with the belief that once it bonds to Eddie,
that Eddie can maintain himself. And if he's able to maintain himself,
he can in turn, travel directly to know,
and then essentially create a back door that allows the superheroes to get in
and find some way to conquer. Now,
the problem with this is that as soon as the Grendel's starts bonding to Eddie,
things start popping off, right? His vitals are just spiking.
It looks like he's going into cardiac arrest.
It's it's too much for his body to handle and him.
And it's one of these things where we don't know if it's because of the injuries
he sustained or if it just simply is too much for him, right?
The nature of the Grindle itself is something that Eddie Brock simply can't
handle on his own. Now the whole time this is going on, right?
The whole time this is happening,
Dylan is trying to get the attention of the whole. He was right there.
Like we got to find a way to pull it off. Right?
We've got to find a way to get this thing off.
We gotta find a way to pull it off. And Dylan's like, guides guys, hold on,
everybody. I need you to move. And they're like, no, this isn't gonna,
we're trying to get this off the whole time. They're ignoring Dylan. Right.
And he's just like, hi. And he like screams. And he's like I said, move.
And then like, blast the semi, like blast the Grendel off of Eddie Brock.
Like literally disintegrates it in one touch.
Now we knew that was the power of Dylan. Right?
Don't have the ability to con to destroy or control. Symbionts right.
We know we have that power. He's very similar to null in that way.
None of the other superheroes knew. And because they're adults,
of course they don't listen to kids because adults feel like they know more than
kids. And in a lot of ways they do,
the kids have something that most adults don't have, which is imagination.
And so this basically leads to them realizing, Oh my God,
this kid can be our secret weapon. Right.
We're obviously not going to have him marching out in New York and start
blasting Symbyax with his hand. No, what scoop him up in an instant. Right?
But he is our secret weapon. If we can formulate a plan around him,
then we can basically find a way to win the,
with this is they start hearing this noise, right?
There's just a kind of this explosion. You have this you'll kind of deep, deep,
you know?
And then it's just beep and that's when you realize Eddie Brock has flatlined.
All the other superheros here,
and Dylan realized that Eddie Brock has basically just died with that
being said, guys, we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain cliffhangers.
If you want to know here to come and explain,
make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a like,
and I will catch you all later.
Bruce.
[inaudible].